vous êtes un vrai de progressistes êtes
vous assez progressistes pour être au
choix pas pro choix parce que je trouve
qu'ils sont un peu à l'extrême mais
aussi moi je suis je pense que je suis
contre l'avortement mais je peux
comprendre certaines situations que des
femmes se fasse avorter et je pense que
c'est par l'éducation qu'on en vient à
ne pas considérer l'avortement comme un
moyen de continuer mais je peux
comprendre que certaines personnes en
arrive à ça et je pense que toutes les
femmes qui se font avorter ne mérite pas
une condamnation mais plutôt de la
compassion
moi j'ai aucune certitude dans ma foi
j'ai toujours dit que la fois c'était
une espérance
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils disaient la
fois que les tiennes ses 23 heures les
trois quarts de 2,15 minutes d'espérance
et c'est exactement ce que j'ai comme
fois je n'ai aucune certitude si vous
vous dites est ce que vous êtes sûr que
j'existe dont je poursuis que dieu
existe
est ce que vous êtes sûr que là que la
ville continue après la mort j'ai aucune
certitude mais j'ai de l'espérance qu'un
jour où on vous disait que je ne suis
plus prête est ce que ça vous briserez
qu'un oui par exemple parce que moi
j'aime l'église je ne travaille pas
contre les jets c'est de quelqu'un m'a
demandé mon écoute sa part des listes si
je veux changer quelque chose dans
l'église c'est à l'intérieur que je peux
le faire c'est pas en sortant j'ai
départ j'ai pas de souffrir
pas de moule et la mort de m et papa
j'étais maire accompagné de jean dans la
boxe en fait papa sauf que j'ai pas de
souffle et je ne veux pas souffler ça
c'est sûr